-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, this is nice.
Today, President Biden hosted
The White House's first-ever
Rosh Hashanah party to celebrate
the Jewish new year.
Yeah. I think Biden was confused
because he ended his speech
by saying, "Now let's watch
Ryan Seacrest do the countdown."
And you go, "No."
Yeah, they celebrated today,
even though Rosh Hashanah
was Monday.
That's like setting off
fireworks on the Ninth of July.
You know what I'm saying?
It's fun, but is it...
But it was a nice party,
although it got awkward when
Biden was
offered challah and said,
"You want me to speak louder?
I want that bread
you're holding.
Holla at your boy, Jack."
Then, a few hours later, the
president hosted a reception for
Hispanic Heritage Month.
Biden's staff was like,
"Hey, might as well
knock out all
the cringey gaffes in one day.
You know what I'm saying?"
Biden held events
for the Jewish New Year
and Hispanic Heritage Month.
Staffers watched Biden the way
Aaron Judge's mom
nervously watches his at bats.
Like, "Come on, buddy.
You can do this.
You can do this. Don't mess..."
Well, get this --
in a televised address,
Vladimir Putin admitted
that Russia made mistakes
in how they drafted troops
for the war.
And then Putin broke into
the most depressing version of
"My Way" you've ever heard.
He's like...
[ Russian accent ]
♪ Regrets, I have a few ♪
♪ But, then again,
too few to mention ♪
[ Normal voice ] Meanwhile
today, Putin illegally claimed
four regions of Ukraine
as part of Russia.
And to celebrate,
Putin and a few other leaders
had a pretty
interesting handshake.
Take a look at this.
[ Applause ]
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Oh!
-Rest easy, Russia.
That guy's
coordinating your war.
That handshake looked like
a sandwich
made up of tiny white sausages,
didn't it?
-Ew!
-Well, this is big.
Earlier tonight,
Elon Musk hosted
Tesla's
Artificial Intelligence Day,
and he was expected to
unveil Tesla Bot,
a humanoid robot
designed to help with
boring, repetitive tasks,
stuff that humans
don't want to do anymore.
For example, Tesla Bot can...
or it can...
It can...
Then it can...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-Some movie news.
Today, 29 years after
the original,
"Hocus Pocus 2"
premiered on Disney+.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The movie looks great.
It's about three witches
who come back to life
after Lizzo starts playing
a 200-year-old flute.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, did you guys see this?
Tomorrow is former president
Jimmy Carter's 98th birthday.
-Ooh!
-Yeah, and this is exciting.
He's also going to run
for a second term.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
It's always nice to
hear about a famous Jimmy
who doesn't host a
late-night talk show, isn't it?
And, finally, I read that a
group of paleontologists
just found fish teeth
that are 14 million years older
than any teeth
found from any other species.
We actually got in contact with
the paleontologists
responsible for the find.
Here's what they had to say.
The first one said...
This next one said...
And, finally,
the last scientist said...